I work for the
women in my country
who are facing crazy mountains
without even having
to step on a mountain.
And I thought of
a campaign to go
climb the highest mountain
of every continent
in the world, knowing that
the struggle in the mountain
was so parallel to the struggle
that women face in society.
(audience clapping)
I like to get outside
and climb things.
Mainly mountains,
but when I was little
the climbing scene
was very different.
I was about six or seven,
and I was living in
this part of Bangladesh,
called Khulna which is very near
The Sundarbans, the largest
mangrove forest in the world
that you may have heard of.
And this is the first time
when I saw white people,
when my fathers office
received these foreigners,
and I didn't know how to
speak English at that time.
I was overly excited,
the officer had a little girl
who had a very nice,
ring-like thing around her
that she was playing with,
later on I found out
it was a hula hoop,
many years later.
So I wanted to be cool,
I wanted to fit in,
and I was obviously
very excited,
and I started playing
with it, with her,
in sign language, whatever.
And this auntie, we
have a lot of aunties
in our society who
dictate things for us,
snapped at me and said
(yelling in Bangla).
Which is so derogatory in Bangla
that it cannot even be
translated in English,
but what it sums up
is that "a good girl
"shouldn't be
shaking their hips."
(crowd laughter)
And I wanted to be a good girl,
and I kept down the hula
and I never played with it.
I was also asked to
stop biking, cycling,
because I would
lose my virginity.
And there are many other
taboos that I believed.
Bangladesh, it's a
land of extremities.
Light, and darkness.
It's a nation of 170
million people approaching.
We don't have many
mountains as you can see.
We don't have any
mountains, we live in water.
But when I was a
child some amazing,
crazy disastrous events
happened in my life.
I lost my home even
before I was a teenager.
My parents divorced and
there was a custody battle,
and I was homeless as a result.
Very early on I had to, as
a child, become an adult,
take responsibility of
basically my existence.
But it was these experiences
that I'm very grateful for.
These mountains that I climbed,
because those are
the experiences
that made me pursue
a better education.
I went on to pursue
another career
fighting for other
people's homes.
Whether that was for women
who were severely abused,
or ostracized, or
for indigenous people
living under crazy regimes,
or refugees without a nation.
And it was my one
particular friendship
and connection that got
me into a lot of trouble.
Not just in China or Tibet,
but at home in Bangladesh.
As an activist who was
working and was very
involved with human
rights work in Tibet,
me and my distant
relatives, colleagues,
my tribe, basically, in
Bangladesh, was being hounded,
by intelligence
forces in Bangladesh
all the time, for years.
My family was basically
very ashamed of me,
but it was during this period
when I found the mountains
as a refuge to heal myself,
but also it was during this
time that I really understood
the definition of
what home means.
And I ask myself "what
is it about Bangladesh
"that really inspires me?
That I feel proud of?"
And it was the women who
were in the forefront
of every movement, whether it
was our liberation movement,
our independence movement,
or other movements,
women were what
defined Bangladesh.
So as Bangladesh approached
40 years in 2011,
there were all kinds of
celebration being planned,
and I thought of
a campaign to go
climb the highest mountain of
every continent in the world,
because I thought
symbolically it was
taking Bangladesh to all
corners of the globe.
And also personally,
just knowing that
the struggle in the
mountain was so parallel
to the struggle that
women face in society.
So The Seven Summits
was first postulated
by a Canadian mountaineer,
Patrick Morrow,
in the early 80s, and
after he finished in 1996,
almost hundreds of people
have accomplished it.
But out of that,
only 32 to 35 were women,
mostly Westerners.
When I first thought
of this I obviously
didn't have the monetary funds.
I ended up convincing the
board of two different banks
to give me bank loans
totally based on trust.
This magical thing
started happening,
all these guardian angels,
and just people who
wanted to help out
in their small ways,
started reaching out.
A rich woman who recently
got out of a relationship,
and you get talaq money,
which is a divorce sum
that you get from your husband,
she gave that all to me and said
"Please go free my
soul on the summit."
I was like "wow!"
And I was so inspired,
and then I got an email
from my former colleague
in the Tibetan movement,
Nima Dorje, says "Oh, by
the way, Patrick Morrow
"lives just by me, do you
wanna hook up with him?"
So I write to him and
Patrick and Baiba, his wife,
invites me to Canada
to train with them.
He set this really
hardcore regime for me,
and then he connected
me to different people
in the seven continents,
which made things easier.
But mind you,
Bangladesh doesn't have
a diplomatic relationship
with almost majority
of these places,
so going to a lot
of these places was
just huge logistical barriers.
But I ended up finishing
five of the seven summits
in the next one
and a half years,
including Chomolungma,
or Mount Everest.
I was so inspired, it was
personally very healing for me.
It was brutally lonely
journey, to say the least.
But in the last four
years, I've gone through
every extreme situation,
from eating my own (bleep),
and poisoning myself,
because my camp got
totally destroyed,
and my toilet got
mixed with my food,
to getting held captive in
Papua, and held for ransom,
to losing my best friends,
I lost four of my best friends
in the last five years,
waking up to earthquakes
and having everything
that you knew being lost,
to getting frostbites and
ending up with medical bills
in a country like the states
without medical insurance,
and going through
intense physical pain,
but this whole journey
gave me a vantage point
to see the earth
from a perspective
that one out of 170
million in my country
has been able to see.
So I'm very grateful,
and I learned a lot.
I got to reflect a lot
on the human experience,
nothing will ever
be the same for me,
I took, as you can see,
a bunch of selfies,
which is a pure indicator
how lonely you are.
(crowd laughter)
This is the time when I
was stuck in the infamous
Hillary Step in a traffic jam,
and I thought traffic jams
only existed in Bangladesh.
(crowd laughter)
But whenever I would
hit rock bottom,
I would remind myself
of the women at home,
and the struggles that
they would go through,
and that would hug me
with a newfound energy,
and I finally managed in
2015 to accomplish a feat,
which by default made me
the first Bangladeshi,
that was not my goal.
Remember that hula?
(crowd laughter)
I took this hula hoop
to The Seven Summits,
I have a waist now
and I can shake it,
but it was not about that,
it was about reclaiming
back what was taken
away from me as a girl child,
and I want to make that
possible for every other girl
that exists in my
country, and in my region.
The other transformation
that happened
is when I came down Everest,
everyone who detested
me came back in my life.
Family members, politicians
who sent intelligence,
and that's exactly
when I realized,
"wow, climbing
mountains solved so many
"problems in this society?"
Had I known that, I
would be pursuing this
probably a year many moons ago.
And I got all kinds
of company offers,
banks wanted to pay off
the debt by themselves,
I got a lot of
marriage proposals.
(crowd laughter)
Marriage proposals at
home come with a biodata,
how you would apply in a job.
So I made my own biodata,
and because it comes
with a mugshot of the groom,
and how much they earn,
and what their father
does, and mother does.
So mine looks like this,
and every time this works.
(crowd laughter)
To sum it up, there
are many other girls
who need to climb
their own mountains.
And what I'm doing now
is using the momentum
of the campaign to gain
support towards my foundation,
Ösel, and it's an
alternate education center,
which combines the
latest scientific finding
about mind-training, and
combines it with mindfulness,
and training in nature
through various activities.
Ösel is a conscious
movement to bring balance
to mother nature
by empowering women
to harness their
inner luminosity.
Thank you so much.
(crowd clapping)